va-t-elle hubert bonisseur de la bath je
voulais vous souhaiter à tous une très
belle et heureuse année 1981
[Musique]
désolé je crois que c'est mon taxi
c'est original
à vous étiez là si nous aimait les
animaux ou les femmes prises et les
hélicoptères retrouvez-nous le 3 février
2021 avait un attentat
vu que je t'avais avait parfois j'étais
occupée ils ont mis ça il ya quelques
années après un cambriolage vous ça fait
pas le quartier beaucoup plus sûr
maintenant
et pourquoi los angeles j'aimerais
démarrer une nouvelle vie
un chat un chien non tu sais quoi vont
se faire un barbecue qui devrait venir
on veut que cet emprunt soit convivial
et vivre on essaye de prendre soin les
uns des autres
[Musique]
vous entendez ce prix je n'entends plus
grand chose
je suis tout le temps fatigué c'est vrai
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu peux faire
courez au score
[Musique]
comment tu as pu faire ça
mais juste pour coutume
[Musique]
c'est ici chez toi
joachim suis dit ce qui était vu que la
voisine au fujian où il cherche une team
bond à la poste
maman je suis flic moi j'suis pas
postiers vous connaissez cet homme les
colombiens sont parvenus à mettre au
point un procédé qui permet de mélanger
la cocaïne avec du ciment
ce qui la rend totalement indétectable
sont arrivés sur ce chantier c'est le
sentier de la famille de almeida unis
faire venir un cousin éloigné du reymond
en substituant à moins d'une semaine
pour faire de vous un vrai portugais non
non je voulais pas ça si je vais faire
de toi ouvrez autour des portes ils
cassent portugaise tap portugal que
c'est l'hélicoptère en nous gouvernent
ou locataire peut souvent faire voir
arrête de faire semblant c'est très bien
c'est un chef
ou surtout de tous genres théâtre
j'espère qu'il va la trouver vite fait
qu'aucun à vos beaux yeux et joue c'est
complet je goûte la qualité manquent en
poudre ou et j'ai une boule en est quand
même c'est pas compliqué je commence
quand pour tout cas on a rappelé il est
devenu carrément savoir les chaises ont
fait grandissent aussi pour beaucoup
jean lacoste en vacances
[Musique]
les progrès film car là il arrive de
passer là tout va bien se passer
la cité
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas chef chez ce que c'est
[Musique]
comment les scop
ça va la dérange pas trop ces missions
cocaïne ou d'amour et dans ce chantier
[Musique]
et puis
c'est un plaisir de vous rencontrer
monsieur dunbar les sculpteurs dunbar et
là ce soir
ok ça suffit on y va il me faut un
autographe les feignasses l'épave
vértiable je suis son plus grand fan à
râler c'est difficile de trouver les
maisons de stars j'utilise l'appli tarn
ap
tu dois faire super attention je veux
pas qu'on accuse de harcèlement mais tu
peux pas venir chez moi me chercher
c'est ma résidence privée écoute mon
pote je sais pas comment tu m'as trouvé
mais je veux plus jamais te revoir dans
ce dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
collet je voulais juste un autographe
attends attends attends tu es un grand
malade
lubitsch à celle de nourrir
les forêts sont peuplés de l'oume c'est
ma mission de les tuer pas la tienne
oui mais alors je sais ensemble d'îles
où les ours mais mes bras gauche
[Musique]
si à ces maudits wolf worker
ces êtres qui parle avec les grottes
avec ses pouvoirs magiques
[Musique]
tu peux sortir maintenant on peut
repérer à l'odeur est tombé
cette embrouille soccer
tlpe dans ton sommeil
ouais
il est belle
[Musique]
robin il m'est arrivé quelque chose ça
je vois c'est trop bien thello
maintenant
grétry si chaque jour
des loups ce ne sont que des bêtes 7
nuls nous mettrons un terme
les premiers à ta mère de payer sur
trois
l'eau
[Musique]
vous devez partir
jamais je ne me serais la trouve
c'était un poisson les arts
d'environ 2 m il a fallu des jours pour
l'extraire il est nettoyé
je n'avait que 11 ans à l'époque
il est au british muséum
celui là était spécial mademoiselle à m
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler de vous par
les membres de la société géographique
de londres qu'est ce que vous voulez
monsieur
[Musique]
ma femme elle ne se porte pas bien
depuis quelque temps elle souffre de
mélancolie
j'aimerais que vous accompagne lorsque
vous étudiez le visage qu'elle apprenne
devant
et pas besoin d'une apprentie je paierai
ce qu'il faudra pour des rencontres
privées c'est pas un travail facile
[Musique]
je déteste l'eau
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce qu'on donne
aux touristes
oui mais figure
je suis ravi que vous vous soyez lié
d'amitié
est ce que c'est
quelque chose
rien
[Musique]
je ne veux pas retourner à la vie qu'ils
avaient avant de te connaître et ma vie
à moi
[Musique]
non
formés
[Musique]
vim
on
combien de temps encore je vais devoir
rester ici j'ai besoin de votre aide
j'ai envie de sentir le feu en moi j'ai
envie d'exploser devant des relations
sexuelles avec un garçon qui a une
voiture c'est quoi une voiture
arrête de broyer du noir rien de ça plus
tôt ils cherchent des auteurs un
concours pour devenir critique de rock
je suis jo-ann amaury kg un entretien
pour l' annonce vous avez trouvé que mon
article été bon quand même c'est pas
vraiment d'aucun
un jury
des types comme eux ont besoin de filles
comme toi
allez on y va
milieu du ciel celle ravisseurs d'enfant
johanna morrigan est morte face à vous
la légendaire d'hollywood
soir encore à 9 heures du rock and roll
ça ne voulait rien dire pour moi à
minuit c'était devenu la chose la plus
importante au monde
chéri c'est moi est ce que tu as déjà
fait carrière je n'ai jamais rien payé
de leur personne
on va dans ces endroits de ce pour
pouvoir danser et leurs liens avec des
gens qui sont prévenus et ont tout
devient poissy
je vous présente dans les voiles non
mais il vrai le problème c'est qu'une
fois qu'on se retrouve du côté obscur de
la force
on ne le voit pas du tout le côté obscur
ses larmes
pas question de jouer la c1 quel moment
tu as pété un câble
on fait quoi quand on se construit et
qu'on se rend compte que
pour se construire on n'a pas lâché on
déchire tout et on recommence
[Musique]
ça ça on aimerait publier dans notre
prochain numéro je suis très touché
merci infiniment maintenant et est-ce
que tu joue un rôle là au moment où je
te parle
[Musique]